Test coverage let’s us assign a score to a collection of test cases
and so let's be a little bit more rigorous about it.
So test coverage is really is a measure of the proportion of a program exercised during testing.
So, for example, we’ve just talked about measuring a number of functions
out of the total number of functions or exercise by some test that we had.
What’s good about test coverage is it gives us a score,
gives us something objective that we can use to try figure out how well we’re doing.
Additionally, when coverage is less than 100%, that is to say, as in our example,
where we had failed to execute all of the functions in the software under test,
we know what we need to do to get full coverage.
We know what the functions are that we need to execute.
Now, we simply need to construct test cases and execute those functions.
So, these are the good things about test coverage.
On the other hand, there are also some disadvantages.
First of all, test coverage, because it is a white box metric that is derived
from the source code for our system is not good at helping us find bugs of omission,
that is to say bugs were simply left out something that we should have implemented.
The second drawback is it could be really hard to know what a test coverage score less 100% means
and in safety critical software development would sometimes done is requiring 100% test coverage
of a certain coverage metrics and that sort of removes this problem,
it means that we don’t have to interpret scores less than 100% because we’re not allowed
to ship our product until we get 100% test coverage.
For a larger, more complex software systems where the standards are correct
and not as high as they are for safety critical systems, that’s often the case,
but it’s difficult or impossible to achieve 100% test coverage.
Leaving us with this problem we’re trying to figure out what that actually means about the software.
The third disadvantage is even 100% coverage doesn’t mean that all bugs are found
and you could see that sort of easily by thinking about the example why we’re measuring
our coverage by looking at the number of functions we executed.
Just we executed some function, of course,
it doesn’t mean that we found all the bugs in that function.
We may not have executed very much of it or may not have somehow
found very many of the interesting behaviors inside that function.